is from dhs department of homeland
security
has decided not to deport
a man named harry berto fuerte padilla
riberto fuerte padilla is an illegal
alien
he was not deported
for the long period of time that he
lived in america he got drunk drove a
car and killed a teenager in texas an
american teenager in texas
killed her oh and then he fled the scene
so it was a hit and run he fled the
scene he was arrested
they were going to deport him finally
too late apparently but they were going
to deport him and then dhs decided nope
we're not going to deport him we're not
even going to deport a drunk driving
illegal alien who killed a teenager
that's what soft on crime means
gen saki the department of homeland
security is refusing to deport a drunk
driving illegal alien who killed a texas
teen furthermore
u.s customs u.s immigration and customs
enforcement ice
has told
texas that it's canceling more
deportation requests these are detainers
on other illegal immigrants
including some people who pled guilty to
felony charges of evading arrest or had
convictions not even just arrests
convictions for drunk driving
drug possession or domestic assault
injuring a family member
they're not going to deport even those
people they're just going to let them
stay
where is this coming from
where is this is this
coming from the the ice agents
they're the ones who say we don't want
to deport them i doubt it
usually the rank and file guys are
interested in doing their jobs it's
usually not their fault when their jobs
are not being done it's usually their
boss's faults the political's faults
so is it alejandra mayorkas fault the
secretary of homeland security
i actually don't think it's his fault i
don't particularly care for that guy
but he was just caught on a hidden
microphone
just just the other day
complaining about this he said the
border situation is the worst it has
been in at least 20 years if not ever
which looks really bad for him i suspect
mayorkas probably wants to enforce the
law at least a little bit more
i think this is coming from biden well i
don't think anything's coming from biden
i don't think biden knows what day it is
but i think that this is coming from
the white house i think this is coming
from
the radical leftist democrats who are
surrounding the president and running
the white house and i think the order is
coming from on high
to dhs to ice
don't deport these people
and it's having really devastating
political effects
for non-radical leftists it's really
ginning up the base
but
the base is not going to win them
elections
really really bad stuff and and mayorkas
looks absolutely terrible
now
the
this guy harry berto fuerte padilla
he would be an example
of a very bad hispanic person in america
a lot of people make new year's
resolutions i'm going to work out i'm
going to eat less i'm going to drink
less i'm going okay right whatever
here's one for you
spend less time at the brick and mortar
auto parts store well you can just go to
rockauto.com they've got an incredibly
easy to navigate catalog
they've got reliably low prices it's not
gimmicks it's not 20 off on tuesday at
11 a.m it's reliably low
it's a family-owned business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years
they've got the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers and you're just going
to save a lot of money you're going to
save a lot of money
you can save 50 on an auto part but
you're also going to save a lot of time
which is money because you're not going
to have to get in the car and drive to
the place and wait in line and then the
guy goes in the back he pepper you know
he first peppers you with questions he
goes in the back they don't have the
part he tells you you gotta wait you
gotta drive back you gotta wait two
weeks don't do it
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and then write knowles k-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
glad you liked that show
ring the bell
ring it you got to ring the bell
ll ring my bell and then if you're still
not getting notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you listen to your audio
podcasts leave a five star review type
in the michael knowles show subscribe
good to go we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you